work on the form and make sure that we
have good form
Michael
Taino henko
what I'd like you to do is I'd like you
to put a key eye in okay not I don't
have a silent practice I was sensor used
to uh he used to have a key eye you
could hear a mile away
Kevin Gavin rather he's got a good key
eye so you must copy his if it's still
the same as last year's so I thought you
hop a handout so if I take up
take with full commitment
so he puts kii in I put Kia in
toe-to-toe
if I was to
if I was to listen
if I was to put
sorry ah if I put more key eye in then
the power power comes out more so we
have to build up slowly so if you don't
hear me making a loud key eye it's only
because I'm trying to save my ukis from
being
put down too hard
this there's a Remy
hostile for the most basic tanahanko hey
adjust this front foot look the same way
as your partner your partner puts his
hand up just in case
by Tammy
okay so please do all these things
hey it's a car wait
many Japanese teachers and teachers have
this for here like this
if you train like that that's okay but
if you have bad knees
uh
like myself cytosency
but it's better to adjust them
I had bad knees with being a motor
mechanic on the concrete floor not
through the Aikido
all right
lift the foot and adjust it and become
firm straight back leg
okay on a gas mask
I
sit comfortably once your knees start to
like
eight
[Applause]
Don't Be Stiff watch my body
if you try to do it too perfect you'll
be stiff and you'll get knocked out
ready
you're knocked out because they're so
strong and you're thinking up here so
perfect that you're you get knocked off
balance
you put Power in here
and then
you sort of you mellow
okay so you you have to the only thing
you have to do is to keep this piece the
center this piece the
watch and now everything is soft you're
just soft there
there's no trick you just have to train
yourself to do it
I'll do the same side hey if I go stiff
look I I block my power and it pushes me
out and all this is no good
too late
see I put Power in I look powerful
and then I try to be comfortable Within
Myself
that's the secret be comfortable within
yourself
you just look stiff
Kino nagali doesn't have to be
quick
kinagari
his controlled speed
controlled speed
so even if he catches
even if he catches here
this is still kinanagawe I is when a
technique doesn't stop
this is not kinanagari
one two three
okay about the same speed
is
so if you ever wonder what the
difference is between kihon and kinan
agawi it's when a technique doesn't stop
it doesn't matter what speed it is
hey
kindergarten
a lot of people think that it's
the third level
this is uh this is the third level this
is a high high level but we don't
normally teach that because you're going
to teach the third downs and above
and by then they should be walking
around like Stone
so
try and make it continuous
if you're doing this already if you're
going
hey
and you think it's keyhan it's not
so you're already doing kindergarten so
that means you need to take a step back
here
you offer your hand at your time
a new turn all in one
if he's got his head down there he can't
see if you hit it or not so he has to
also look after his posture he
good
see he can see
please try okay
Michael
this one would earn a Remy footwork
the footwork is slightly different
[Music]
from here you're going to shift this
back leg behind him
lift up
don't take new Cami just keep a Supple
back
then don't look
didn't hear it
hey
Sansa
step behind push off this leg
push off the legs the straight leg and
down look just tight don't take a new
Cami
if someone Falls that's okay because it
sometimes happens hey ah
the seniors or the people that find it
easy can do it more on motion
hey
this
can be more in one motion Legend hands
hey
[Applause]
can be can be like push off your leg
push off your leg
okay
you can always uh it take anybody can
throw somebody down but not everybody
can make a good movement
hey
ah not everybody can make harmony with
this person's body
the reason why you don't look is he may
come up with his legs and kick her in
the face so you have your arms to
protect you
look at your mouse
please this is the motion
okay but if I do that especially in
Scotland if I do it in Scotland you'll
think I'm all ever ready to fight hey
the light soft from here it's not really
the arm the arm just locates hey under
the chin
but the hips do the work
that's what you should be
searching for
a
so you need something to show your
partner with you can't just go
okay this that works later on when we
become
I think
higher standard
so here
we're going to now go to Cuff hold
and you have to turn your arm
if you bend it like this
he blocks you
if you turn it ah you can do this and
then you're you're the same
so slowly
you may ask why would anybody catch you
here a martial art this would cut if a
martial art is catches you here
oh he's on top so that means now he
could pin me so that's not so good but
if I hold I think your ghee's gonna tear
I hold
in the car
oh that's going to tell as well
I can do uh techniques on him I should
find somebody who can afford to buy a
ghee
[Applause]
mine's in good shape
so that's why he would hold there
because he could spin me over and Pin Me
Down
oh turn your arms
no Cami
push off your straight leg
either one and now the leg
push off the straight leg
you have to become flexible
this bit you have to do I can't do that
for you hey
those of you who can work it out can do
arms and leg
hey
arms and legs
push off your straight leg
really push another one bends the hips
turn
you guys fast
behind the chin
this one
the striker is
a
h
this is but you can use this
the form
ah
either left and then step or
distance that
turn the hands
[Music]
arm up
it's
one more time
hey
ah
I push off the leg they're all the same
and just to here
[Applause]
so it's exactly the same I knew you grab
the
category it holds strong
somebody my size could more than likely
bend it if I tried hard enough
but it's the kosher the hips that move
it I now look the same way
I lift up
and step back and now I turn
I was thinking of something the other
day while teaching
and you'll notice sometimes with the
feet those of you are good with your
eyes ah
perhaps always you don't quite get as
deep as you'd like
and nobody tells you about the extra
step
so now with the back leg I go
and I'm not far enough
so I'm starting to have to work hard to
move him
so I need this leg to move up but I'm
already committed so it's difficult
to bring the leg in to do this
and that wouldn't be that wouldn't be
any good
so
you have to do
and then bring this leg in you have to
make the adjustment now you have to
bring the leg in One
one
so because you need then to find the
distance
you can't find it afterwards
so
so here
so if you bring it in deep if not bring
it in a little
and then turn
in a moment we'll do all of the madhu
Cami ah
if it's okay you just do it
but if you need a little some extra
eat if it's not far enough
you bring it in
and then you do this
okay it teachers usually tell you only
how to do it this way this way this way
but even the teachers even uh my senior
teachers that I train under they still
they do this and then you'll just see
them make a small movement
but I don't tell you about that
so you have to uh
you have to be you have to know that
it's okay to do it
but you have to adjust it first it's no
good adjusting afterwards okay please
try
we're done with it okay
you've got so many things to remember
but the biggest thing is don't look
you may be training even with a an ugly
person so that's a even a better
Point not to look
then we sleeve hold they do one of each
Dory
so the door
and then cut up
okay
try not to let yourself get carried away
off
there mustn't be any aggression
okay so all the ones you've done one
two
three
four
try not to get carried away you can do
at this pace and it's uh
I remember the foot if you need it step
twice
you can do that that's fine
mix smooth David